OVERCHARGED.
I'M JUST SAYING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE ABOUT A DECADE
AGO, BUT IT WAS ONLY ONE
CALENDAR YEAR FROM TODAY AS THE
CREEPY PORN LAWYER WAS ALL OVER
TV.
THEY WERE TELLING US THAT HE WAS
PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL, IN CASE
YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN.
>> THIS PRESIDENT ALL BUT
ACKNOWLEDGED VLADIMIR PUTIN AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS, CHRIS, AS TO
WHY THE PRESIDENT WOULD NOT WANT
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
RUSSIAN COLLISION SITUATION.
UNLESS HE KNOWS HE'S GUILTY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, FOR YOU TO
LOVE STOMACH LIVE AS A
MANCHURIAN CANDIDATE AND ARE
WHITE HOUSE --
>> WHY AM I ON CNN SO MUCH?
GUESS WHAT?
THIS IS WHY.
>> WE WILL NEVER BE PART OF ANY
EFFORT TO SNOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, PERIOD.
>> Tucker: WELL, BECAUSE, IT
IS ABSOLUTELY REAL, THINGS
PROMPTLY WENT SOUTH FOR THE
CREEPY PORN LAWYER.
EXTORTION, THEFT, TAX EVASION,
AND LOTS OF OTHER THINGS.
BUT HE IS A SPORTY CHARACTER.
HE'S NOT READY TO GIVE UP JUST
YET.
TODAY, HE PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
WHAT IS NEXT FOR HIM?
MARK STEYN HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS CASE AS CAREFULLY AS A
LAYMAN CAN.
SO IS THERE A HOPE THAT HE STAYS
OUT OF THE BIG HOUSE?
>> NOT REALLY BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WINS 99%
OF ITS CASES.
97% OF THEM WITHOUT EVER TAKING
THEM TO TRIAL.
THAT IS A RATE OF SUCCESS THAT
KIM JONG UN WOULD ENVY.
SO HE IS UP AGAINST SOME PRETTY
STIFF THOUGHTS, AND I LOVE ALL
THE STUFF, YOU KNOW.
I BELIEVE IN THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
I DO TOO.
I'M WITH HIM ON THAT, BUT IN THE
END, THE REALITY OF THE FEDERAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, BOTH FOR THIS
GUY AND FOR THE ACTRESS THAT
TRACE WAS TALKING ABOUT, AT SOME
POINT, YOU'RE LOOKING AT 475
YEARS IN JAIL IF YOU GO TO
TRIAL.
SO YOU TEND TO COP A PLEA.
THAT HER HEROIC MOMENT HERE, I
WILL BE INTERESTED TO SEE, IF
THAT SURVIVES ALL THE WAY TO THE
COURTHOUSE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
PREJUDGE THE SITUATION, AND I'M
NOT A JUROR HERE.
I'M NOT EVEN A LICENSED
ATTORNEY, BUT ALL I KNOW IS WHEN
HE SAT IN THE STUDIO THIS FALL,
OUR STAGE MANAGER, WHO IS A
PRETTY STURDY CHARACTER, WAS
RATTLED TV IN HIS PRESENCE.
SO CREEPY WAS HIS PRESENCE.
I DON'T THINK -- THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HELP HIM IN COURT.
>> NOW, IT WON'T, AND THE
REALITY IS THAT IF IT WEREN'T
FOR THIS, HE WOULD HAVE FOUND
OUT THAT WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENCE DINNER, AND THEY
WOULD HAVE SAID HE'S SPEAKING
TRUTH TO POWER.
AND THEY WOULD HAVE DONE ALL OF
THAT FLIMFLAM WITH HIM, AND HE
IS JUST A ROTTEN, SLEAZY LAWYER,
WHO, GOES HIS CLIENTS ACCOUNT,
WHICH IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS
THE ONE THING -- THE CALIFORNIA
ETHICS CODE IS THE SHORTEST ON
THE PLANET FOR CALIFORNIA
BAR ASSOCIATION.
THAT'S THE ONE THING YOU CAN
STILL BE NAILED ON.
HE'S NOT I HEROIC PRESIDENTIAL
SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER A GUY,
HE'S JUST A FLIMFLAM SHYSTER WHO
STEALS FROM HIS CLIENTS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SO RIGHT.
>> YOU COULD SEE THIS, AND THE
WHITE HOUSE COULDN'T.
>> Tucker: HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
THERE, SIPPING FOR PSYCHO.
SO WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, BUT IT
HAD YOUR NAME ALL OVER IT.
THE PRESIDENT VOWED TO WAGE WAR
ON CANADA IF THEY DIDN'T STOP
DUMPING GARBAGE INTO THE
PHILIPPINES.
WE EXPLAINED LAST NIGHT, IF IT
IS WAR, THE PHILIPPINES HAS OUR
FULL SUPPORT.
>> I AM SHOCKED THAT HE WOULD
SEND HIS GARBAGE TO THE
PHILIPPINES.
A STRUGGLING THIRD WORLD COUNTRY
NEEDS MORE GARBAGE?
IT SEEMS SO INSENSITIVE.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE A FORM OF
COLONIALISM.
GARBAGE COLONIALISM.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A QUESTION
OF INSENSITIVITY.
YOU KNOW, TUCKER, OUR
PRIME MINISTER IS VERY, VERY
SENSITIVE.
>> Tucker: THEN WHY IS HE
SENDING THOSE BOTTLES TO MANILA?
IT SEEMS LIKE WHITE PRIVILEGE TO
ME.
I'M JUST THROWING THAT OUT THER
THERE.
>> Tucker: SO IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY HAVE SAID THEIR COUNTRY IS
SCRAMBLING TO BRING THAT BACK.
>> YEAH.
>> WE HAVE ALREADY INDICATED
THAT WE WILL TAKE IT BACK.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT BOTH
GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO WORK ON.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY AT
THIS POINT.
WE ARE WORKING AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN.
>> Tucker: SO, CANADA JUST GOT
BACK DOWN BY THE PHILIPPINES?
>> NOW, THIS IS TERRIBLE, TUCKE
TUCKER.
THESE ARE USED ADULT DIAPERS I
CANADA -- WHEN WE GO TO WORK, WE
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
USING THEM ON THE DOCK IN
MANILA.
YOU ARE WRONG TO BLAME JUSTIN
TRUDEAU FOR THIS.
THESE ARE ADULT DIAPERS, AND
HE'S STILL ON CHILD SIZE.
SO IF YOU CONTINUE TO PROVOKE
US, TUCKER, WITH ALL OF YOUR
RATTLING TO CANADA, WE HAVE READ
THAT POEM AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY ABOUT THE
WRETCHED REFUSE OF YOUR TEEMING
SHORE.
THIS IS THE MOST AMOUNT OF
REFUSE ON THE MOST TEEMING SHORE
IN HISTORY.
WE ARE GOING TO DROP IT OFF ON
THE HARBOR IN NEW YORK IF YOU
DON'T BACK OFF.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: WE WOULD HAVE TO
BEAT YOU OUT A PILLOW FIGHT IF
THAT HAPPENS.
DO YOU THINK AS A CANADIAN, IS
AS DAMAGING DAMAGING THAT
NATIONAL THAT MOST CANADIANS
FEEL DEEP INSIDE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS ACTUALLY
A BEAUTIFUL THING BECAUSE THIS
IS RECYCLING AND ACTION.
BEFORE, WE JUST USE YOU
TOSSED -- I GET MY DIAPERS FROM
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION BECAUSE
THEY ARE TAX-DEDUCTIBLE.
BEFORE WE JUST USE TO TOSS THEM
IN THE LANDFILL.
NOW WE NEED TO SAVE THE PLANET,
SO LET'S SHIFT ON ALL THE WAY TO
THE PHILIPPINES AND LET THEM
SITTING ON THE DOCK IN THE
PHILIPPINES FOR SIX YEARS.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW WHY?